je vais passer tout de suite la parole à
arnold sur les questions de commerce
international parce que ça nous occupe
aussi beaucoup à bruxelles
alors je vais vous parler de simplement
d'un seul dossier qui était à l'ordre du
jour bonjour à tous je suis un homme que
je lis action agriculteurs en normandie
et donc j'ai à la fnsea je m'occupe des
négociations internationales notamment
la négociation ce qu'on appelle souvent
type en anglais mais en français c'est
peut-être intéressant de connaître le
terme cpt cic partenariat
transatlantique pour le commerce et
l'investissement
voilà pour le commerce et
l'investissement donc ça peut peut-être
à la fois faire en sorte que le commerce
se développe et que l'investissement
soit aussi quelque chose vers lequel on
peut se lancer
donc vue à la française c'est déjà un
peu moins effrayant quand on le traduit
comme ça
néanmoins quand je vais vous sortir les
éléments qui concerne l'agriculture
c'est un peu plus inquiétant nous dans
la négociation en est au 12e round de
négociations c'est à dire que les
négociateurs s'enferme pendant une
semaine une fois aux etats unis une fois
en europe et sa lieu ce mois-ci à
bruxelles ça fait trois mois qui se sont
pas réunies et il essaye de voir comment
comment libéraliser les choses le
commerce est régi à la fois par des
normes et à la fois par des barrières
tarifaires l'énorme la volonté de la
commission européenne comme la volonté
des américains c'est de faire en sorte
que l'un et l'autre nous reconnaissions
les pratiques sanitaires des du
partenaire européen ou américain comme
acceptable d'un point de vue commercial
personne n'a envie de les accepter
techniquement pour la compétitivité de
ces éleveurs ou de ses producteurs ou de
ces industries par contre d'un point de
vue commercial dire ce que la food and
drug administration' aux états unis où
l'efsa en europe reconnaît comme ça on
est capable de le valider c'est les
histoires de de chlorine vous avez
entendu parler de poulets au chlore en
fait les aux états unis
pour lutter contre les infections on met
un petit peu de chlore sur sur la sur
les volailles en bout de chaîne
l'abattoir s'est pratiqué de façon très
régulière et c'est très efficace d'un
point de vue sanitaire
et ça permet surtout aux américains de
ne pas avoir tout le système
d'épidémiosurveillance qu'on a dans
notre pays dans les élevages et dans
toutes les pratiques autour de
l'abattage et ça donne énormément de
compétitivité des états unis il faut que
vous sachiez qu'en ce moment la
commission pouce pour qu'on reconnaisse
ça il ya eu un avis favorables de
l'agencé européenne de l'efsa sanitaire
disant que cette pratique était saine
et donc aujourd'hui n'est toujours pas
autorisé dans l'union européenne mais il
ya une volonté que ça soit autorisée
d'un point de vue relation avec le
consommateur vu ça va être une raison de
plus soit en divorce avec le
consommateur on n'a vraiment pas besoin
de ça et ça devrait plutôt être une
raison de mettre en avant notre façon de
faire et c'est surtout une dernière on
va garder toute la contrainte qu'on a en
europe et en plus on va accepter que ces
volailles américaines jeudi c'est
l'élément le plus fort le plus
emblématique mais on a la même chose
dans le dans la production porcine paul
auffray vous peut-être pas parlé tout à
l'heure de la ractopamine il utilise un
antibiotique est un facteur de
croissance aux états unis ce alors c'est
pas une hormone mais ça va dans le dans
le même être dans le même esprit qui
donne énormément de compétitivité à
l'élevage américain de porc et après ils
s'exportent tous leurs portes dans le
monde
il y en a c'est pas autorisé dans
l'union européenne c'est totalement
interdit en production comme en
consommation l'idée quand même des
négociateurs c'est de faire encore en
sorte que l'union européenne accepte ça
voilà ça c'est vraiment des choses très
difficiles à à mesurer et c'est soutenu
par un certain nombre de pays européens
oui comprenez que quand il ya là on
parle beaucoup de guerre en ce moment la
télévision la vraie guerre c'est la
guerre économique que il qu'il y as
entre l'agriculture française marché
solvable
consommant pas mal avec les autres
régulateurs européens qui ont les
élevages plus compétitifs parce que
moins de charges sur la main d'oeuvre
moins de charges environnementales moins
de charges sur les bâtiments et et qui
derrière cherche à nous prendre des
parts de marché c'est la réalité tous
les jours avec les allemands c'est la
réalité tous les jours avec l'espagne et
je ne parle pas des pays du nord donc ça
c'est une vraie inquiétude dont je vous
ai parlé du port de la volaille sur la
viande bovine
s'il ya un boulevard pour les américains
son sens que l'union européenne a
proposé l'importation de 300 mille
tonnes de viande bovine dans les
négociations om c'est la dernière fois
qu'on a qu'on a eu un volume a proposé
300 mille tonnes
ça fait pas grand chose ça fait 3 % de
la consommation européenne
un peu plus de 3% mais les américains
consommant de la viande hachée donc
plutôt des débats morceaux ils sont
capables d'exporter très bon marché des
du filet de l'entrecôte etc
il y avait déjà une partie qui rentre
chez nous et par rapport à l'élevage
français qui est un élevage à lherm
généralement produit dans le centre de
la france on est en rien avec la taille
des ateliers américain en rien avec la
taille de leur abattoir et on n'est en
rien compétitif donc c'est ça ce serait
catastrophique
et puis je vais avoir un mot pour les
grandes cultures sinon philippe pinta va
me le reprocher je voudrais pas qu'il
est l'heure de la politique américaine
là ce qui les bossus mais il ya il a le
verbe est encore très fort le la
politique américaine fait que quand les
prix baissent leur raid augmente
nous sommes en europe avec un petit peu
comme la france en 1939 en 1914 toujours
en retard d'une guerre
c'est à dire grands en europe on donne
la même aide à l'hectare quel que soit
la production quand qu'on fasse pas ce
qu'il faut surtout pas qu'on pousse les
gens à être productif aller dans tel ou
tel sens alors que les américains sont
d'un pragmatisme et d'une efficacité
extraordinaire ça va mal dans le secteur
on soutient on se fait attaquer le à
l'om science on se débrouille mais on
soutient
nous on est on donne la même aide à
l'hectare sur tout
pas de distorsion entre tout le monde et
ça ne sert à rien c'est d'une
inefficacité et si le prix des céréales
arrivé à baisser comme il est en train
de baisser à continuer dans la pente ou
y est ça serait catastrophique et on
serait vraiment concurrencer par par ces
américains à tous points de lui sont
très compétitifs
ce que la commission européenne n'a pas
compris c'est qu'on négocie en termes
d'agriculture avec un géant
la commission se dit je pense qu'il a
compris avec le japon ont négocié avec
l'accord et ça se passe très bien on a
su très bien les défendre mais là on
joue pas dans la même division et très
honnêtement un autre je pense qu'ils le
savent très bien
c'est aussi le rôle le rôle des
parlements tel rôle du conseil de faire
et d'être aussi pragmatique que le sont
les américains pour faire en sorte qu on
ne brade pas l'agriculture française et
qu'une fois de plus elle soit dans un
accord international une variable
d'ajustement quelles que soient les les
secteurs concernés
2 ces quatre ans en ciel on a de
l'ambition sur les produits laitiers
on est très fort on est compétitif on en
vend de plus en plus aux états unis il
ya des barrières douanières importante
et ils reconnaissent pas nos indications
géographiques
on a la volonté d'avancer là dessus et
sur les vins et spiritueux
il y a de la taxation petite barrière à
20 20 % de droits de douane
si elle pouvait sauter ça augmente la
compétitition la compétitivité de ses
produits dans des filières qui vont bien
dans notre pays mais si elles peuvent
aller encore mieux moi
seigneur vous n'avez pas l'argent mais
témoin à côté de ceux qui en ont merci
arnold pour